all right my talk of the table looking
forward to right now is the daily show's
jordan klepper best known for
interviewing trump supporters at rallies
all across america his new special takes
things much much further last month
after speaking with people at the
conservative political convention cpac
kepler went to the european country of
hungary at cpac he had asked u.s
conservatives why so many seem to look
to hungary and its authoritarian leader
as a model for america's future
what do you think about donald trump
when he called vladimir putin a genius
was that him being tough i think he has
a way of um
playing with words yeah definitely like
saying the the opposite of what a
patriot and then he gets the media riled
up he disregards his own intelligence
community instead he kisses vladimir
putin but that's him just being smart
it's being a wise guy he's being a wise
guy the market crowd's obsessions were
predictable is this a little much but
there was a new infatuation i was
surprised to hear because for the first
time at cpac people were applauding
another country hungary's on the
forefront when you see people like
leaders in hungary talking and speaking
the way that donald trump did when he
was in office it inspires me
the special is called jordan klepper
fingers the globe hungry for democracy
it'll air on comedy central why don't we
feel like a
practical joke is being played
with that title
you shouldn't have comedians on your
show more respectable i do enjoy it and
the lawyers require me to say that cbs
is a division of uh the paramount global
company uh uh daily show is part of that
and you've convinced our uh fine
corporate leaders to send you on a
european vacation where you also did
some work exactly i think that's the
that's the little trick i pulled there
it's been a long couple years send me to
eastern europe and turns out democracy
is crumbling there too but you had a
serious point exactly so why did you do
it well and why hungry that's what i
think is so interesting you know
hungary's suddenly been a part of the
cultural conversation here tucker
carlson has done a special over there we
went to cpac where a lot of
conservatives get their marching orders
for what's next and they're literally
holding a cpac in budapest so we were
curious what is it about hungary that
conservatives see as a potential
american future so we went
so are you surprised to see that people
there say that joe biden is fake that
his presidency is not legit somebody
even brought up hunter biden's laptop i
was so i was blown away by that yeah
that was a topic of conversation in
hungary i thought i was escaping those
conversations for a mere 10 days but
when we land there march 15th they have
a giant event and i was shocked i
thought we were going to talk about what
was happening in ukraine which is
literally next door to hungary hunter
biden's laptop came out of their mouth
so it felt like i hadn't gone very far
so the other really amazing thing is how
hungary has declined from a near
democracy to what is being qualified as
a authoritarian state by many observers
and in your piece i learned that the
opposition leader the guy trying to
replace the current leader got five
minutes of state television over a
four-year period yeah that's astounding
yeah you go early in the morning yeah it
was really in the morning actually same
time slot you're having right now which
is a great time wonderful you gotta
utilize that that time stamp uh but you
look at it essentially the amount of
time that i'm gonna be on this program
is too little i've been telling your
producers this but uh the hungarians
have been talking about that as well
like if you go to hungary they're having
an election it is a democracy but what
you see is there's only one candidate
that anybody's hearing from and that's
affecting the outcome and that's my
question which is it is a democracy it's
part of the eu these things don't happen
overnight it's not that all of a sudden
hungary woke up and it's in the
situation that you're seeing on the
ground now how did it happen and how do
you see the antecedents here in the u.s
well it's a slide from democracy towards
autocracy to go from free to partly free
and basically what happens is they
affect uh make voting harder there's a
lot of gerrymandering they control the
media most of the media there is owned
by wealthy oligarchs who have
connections to the ruling party and they
vilify certain minority groups the lgbtq
uh community is being vilified right now
to rev up voters and you look at what's
happening in florida right now and you
start to see that thing happening here
and so when you see this democracy slide
in a european country
uh it's that frog boiling in water
democracy is fragile and so when you're
back here in america look it might look
a lot like what's happening before you
realize when the frog realizes hey i'm
dying in here yeah getting really hot i
mean you said in the special that you
wanted to go to get some sense of where
america was heading you
briefly touched on that what conclusions
did you draw democracy is fragile and
you have to stay vigilant
when people talk about the downfall of
american democracy it can be very
hyperbolic and hard to imagine and you
look at hungary it's beautiful travel to
budapest people are wonderful and they
do vote they they do have a media system
that looks on the outside like it's an
open free democracy but underneath
people who are in power are making it
harder and harder for things to change i
think america needs to look very closely
at that how about misinformation what
role does that play we know what it
plays here in the united states what
role does it play in countries like
hungary well when i'm talking to people
on the streets i'm talking to folks
about george soros being the boogeyman
who controls things talking about joe
biden being a fake president and they're
getting some of our misinformation
they're in bubbles like we're in bubbles
over there and again if all you're
exposed to day in and day out is one
party's view of the world and a
distraction from what's happening
literally in the world literally next
door you're going to be caught up in
kind of this echo chamber you also
talked about ukraine with a spokesperson
from the government from from uh
president orland it was very interesting
to see their reaction to putin
could you talk about that for a minute
well like orbit they did not want to
call call putin out yeah
their leader victor orban is very cozy
with vladimir putin he said it's too
early to tell too early to tell exactly
who's responsible here well i think you
know you start to see a lot of this
rhetoric echoed in the conversation here
uh they make no uh
victor orban was very cozy with vladimir
putin and to his supporters that's it's
a tough time to be cozy with vladimir
putin so when you address is that an
issue now they point fingers somewhere
else
you've got to be getting recognized a
lot at these conferences yeah right like
when you're on the street people still
talk to you yes occasionally i will say
this
and tony
i don't know the people who go to those
rallies watch your show and watch the
daily show they watch i went to cpac uh
full of conservatives and i kind of
expected to be a public enemy number one
and i took selfies the entire time uh
and i pulled up they turned into dart
boards they turned into artboards really
quick but i think for many people uh
even if you're the heel in this world
they view it as entertainment so they
want to be a part of the world even if
you're not so supposedly on the side of
the person they support i'm using
ourselves to death i love it yeah jordan
klepper thank you very much jordan's
special premieres tomorrow on comedy
central
up next we're going to talk with